the MBA it takes a lot of jumpshot
salutely he's not a three-point guy I'm
not really a couple of game
Mitchell deep bang [ __ ] about threes red
hot said this last night he has great
balance to a shot in the form is always
perfect and he has good art nailing it
Berto laid one on easy when it comes off
his fingertips in six New Orleans
Mitchell puts up a Walmart layup sweep
out put it back up left hand look at the
hop he is just not
to go in there at the big guy I'll be
shoot Mitchell takes a baseline dump it
better to hand in my deep face seven and
a half favors shut down the first
quarter Rondo stolen Rubio got it back
saved it Rubio again steps in front of
the pass and Mitchell flies it to Jonas
easy two hammers down with two hands
continue to push the pelicans here he is
driving slidin inside off the glass
around DeMarcus Cousins around 20 a game
Mitchell ref slice dice counted you've
gotta be kidding me
with mr. Mitchell here in Salt Lake City
mr. cousins a little euro-step right
biome some good length good good shot
contest' by Udo over the downhill club
by Mitchell sweets FA food always tastes
lucky he didn't get hurt there a game
timeout New Orleans the big fella
running and then 8d takin it hard
watching Anthony go right hard into the
back he leaves with 19 points 10
rebounds a couple of steals Mitchell out
of the timeout fires up another three
Mitchell right to left
scooped it up and in he's got that extra
gear Donovan Mitchell blow by speed he's
got Mitchell slides inside all just pure
speed and the first career 30 point game
for Donovan and they do attack cousins
in the pick-and-roll
here's angles three J calico from
downtown
no three and to keep the ball Michels
hands Donavan slides in the paint scoop
it up and two more unreal unreal they're
gonna put cousins to the pick-and-roll
again Mitchell again just no answer from
the pelicans they can't stay in front of
Mitchell they're using cousins man to
pick and that is just giving Donovan